easter's coming up yeah and i'm guessing
i know that when you get it you get into
the holidays you enjoy your holidays i
like a holiday i'm not gonna lie and i
really love easter because i have this
farm and um and we have 21 chickens and
they produce 21 eggs every day
so we have every year an egg
extravaganza right and and and and so
you it sounds like you take easter more
seriously maybe than most parents is
that fair to say that the the egg
tradition i'm into it i'm into the eggs
and we do you know egg toss and egg and
spoon races and then i was like trying
to think of new games you could play
with eggs and so i went online and
there's this game you can play with them
tube socks so you put up tube socks and
then you stuff as many eggs into your
tube socks as possible and then you have
to run a race
and whoever
ends up
at the end of the race with the least
amount of broken eggs wins that's a
terrible game
it's actually super fun because the
adults get competitive and we started to
like whack at each other's shins and
ankles and like grab each other and take
each other down and my friends
especially me
um because i'm a little bit competitive
you're a little competitive yeah and so
there's just yolk flying everywhere
literally it is disgusting there's eggs
and it smells like rotten eggs for about
three weeks but okay it's fun yeah
nothing you say nothing you said sounds
fun
now you went to the white house for
easter did you not yeah last year i went
um yeah i went they asked me to do the
easter egg roll and i i went because i
was super excited and i'd never been
invited to the white house i went to the
white house one other time
and um but so this was my second time to
the white house and i got to take a
picture with obama
and i'm i'm pretty sure
we're kind of like good friends but i'm
not
because i you know it's kind of like he
waved at me and he kind of winked and my
friend was like oh my god he went to you
and then he hugged me and said hi rhys
and i was like yeah yeah
and i'm pretty sure if you know things
were different and he didn't have like
the busiest job in the world we'd
probably be
buddies really you really think you got
that vibe yeah and michelle and i
already forget about it we're like
girlfriends from way back
what was the first time you met him you
said it was for a movie i think yeah
paul read and i were making a movie in
um washington called how do you know and
we went and we were just like let's take
the tour of the white house and we ended
up taking a tour and then they sent us a
message that the president wanted to
meet us and so we had to scurry over to
the west wing i was like oh my god can
you believe this happening he's like i
can't believe this is happening
my ears started sweating my knees were
sweating and we met him and we went into
the oval office and
i literally i mean paul became silent
which is hard to imagine because he
talks a lot yeah and then i literally i
started talking milo mino because that's
what i do i'm really nervous i'm sure
you can't tell
because what are you doing here and i
started making a movie with paul rudd
and he goes yes i see paul is here and i
said yes that's right that's right and i
make another and i'm making a movie with
owen
owen and i totally froze and i could not
remember i was making a movie with owen
wilson i could not i couldn't remember
his last name i didn't even remember his
name i like i so it paul goes wilson
i was like so he said
so he said nothing at this point and
then suddenly just listen
oh and wilson that's what i meant yeah
and we walked out and paul and i were
pretty convinced that at that point we
would we would definitely be best
friends
i'm sure you would